WALL-TO-WALL VIDEO OF THE
CARAVAN VISIT BECAUSE WHATEVER
YOU THINK ABOUT THE PEOPLE IN
IT, THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THEY
ARE SOME KIND OF INVADING ARMY
WITH TERRORISTS LOOMING ON THE
U.S. BORDER.
>> THE IDEA THAT WE ARE UNDER
THREAT FROM THESE POOR,
DESPERATE PEOPLE IS ABSURD!
IT'S THE BOTTOM OF THE BARREL
POLITICS HE ENGAGE IN.
>> Laura: THAT COMES AS NEW
REPORTS THAT YET ANOTHER CARAVAN
IS FORMING FROM HONDURAS.
YESTERDAY'S "WASHINGTON POST"
REPORTED THERE IS A SINKING
FEELING THAT MORE CARAVANS ARE
YET TO COME AND WILL ONLY GET
LARGER.
TO THE LEFT THIS IS A SCARE
TACTIC.
MAYBE TRUMP IS FORMING THE
CARAVANS HIMSELF.
ACCORDING TO MORNING JOE.
>> THIS CARAVAN, DONALD TRUMP
AND FOX NEWS KEEP TALKING ABOUT
AND THE PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT.
IS SOME LAST DITCH SAD PATHETIC
EFFORT TO AGAIN USE WHITE
PEOPLE, NON-WHITE PEOPLE TO
SCARE WHITE PEOPLE INTO VOTING
FOR REPUBLICANS.
IT'S 1,000 MILES AWAY.
WHAT?
THEY MAY NOT BE HERE UNTIL?
WAIT, WHAT?
>> Laura: THAT'S SO NOT FUNNY.
ANN COULTER IS JOINING US WITH
HER THOUGHTS.
DO YOU THINK THE LEFT HERE
THINKS WE SHOULD NOT BE
CONCERNED AT ALL ABOUT A MASSIVE
CARAVAN BARRELLING TO THE U.S.
BORDER?
A POLITICAL HYPE JOB OR A COMBO?
>> THEY WANT THESE CARAVANS TO
KEEP COMING.
THEY HAVE BEEN COMING A LONG
TIME.
THE ATTACK ON WHITE PEOPLE AND
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE AFRAID OF.
THIS COUNTRY IS BARELY MAJORITY
WHITE ANYMORE.
WE ARE STILL A COUNTRY, THOUGH.
ALL OF THE PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY AGAIN BARELY MAJORITY
WHITE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH LONGER
THEY CAN KEEP SAYING SCARED
WHITE PEOPLE.
WE ARE ALLOWED TO DECIDE WHO
COMES IN AND WHO DOESN'T COME
IN.
>> THE FACT THAT CNN SAID WE ARE
NOT COVERING IT WALL-TO-WALL.
I IMAGINE THAT'S PART OF A
POLITICAL CALCULATION BY OTHER
NETWORKS.
PEOPLE SAY HOW IS THIS FAIR WHEN
ALL OF THESE OTHER PEOPLE HAVE
TO APPLY AND SPEND MONEY
APPLYING AND DO IT THE RIGHT
WAY?
IT COMES DOWN TO A BASIC SENSE
OF FAIRNESS.
NOT THAT WE ARE NOT
COMPASSIONATE?
>> RIGHT.
I HEAR TRUMP SAYING THIS.
FAIRNESS TO IMMIGRANTS WHO DO IT
THE LEGAL WAY.
HOW ABOUT FAIRNESS TO AMERICANS?
ILLEGAL ALIEN CHILD MOLESTER IS
COSTING UTAH TAXPAYERS MORE THAN
$1 MILLION FOR HIS CANCER
TREATMENTS.
THAT SHOULD BE GOING TO AN
AMERICAN CANCER PATIENT.
SITTING IN JAIL AND GETTING FULL
CANCER TREATMENTS.
THE OBSESSION WITH EVERYTHING
GOING ON FAR AWAY FROM US.
WE HAVE TROOPS ALL OVER THE
WORLD AND IN AFGHANISTAN AND IN
SYRIA.
WE ARE NOT PAYING ATTENTION TO
WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT ON OUR
BORDER.
IT'S LIKE A WAR IN CENTRAL
AMERICA.
THAT'S ALL WE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
THIS IS OUR PROBLEM WHAT IS
HAPPENING AT THE BORDER.
THERE IS A REASON THAT
AMERICANS -- MAYBE TRUMP AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY THE CHANTS DURING HIS
CAMPAIGN WAS BUILD THE WALL, BUT
THE PEOPLE HAD A REASON.
SO WE DON'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH
FIGHTING OVER A CARAVAN EVERY 2
MONTHS.
THEY SLIP THROUGH.
WHAT CAN WE DO?
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS THE
PRESIDENT CAN DO BESIDES BUILD
THE WALL THEMSELVES.
HE IS THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
THE MILITARY CAN'T DO ANYTHING
STANDING ON OUR SIDE OF THE
BORDER.
ARE THEY GOING TO SHOOT THE
INVADERS?
THEY COULD GO 10 YARDS INTO
MEXICO.
WE DIDN'T ASK FOR IRAQ'S
APPROVAL TO GO IN.
OTHER THAN SITTING ON OIL, MOST
OF THE MIDDLE EASTERN COUNTRIES
WON'T KILL AMERICANS.
LOTS OF AMERICANS ARE KILLED IN
DRUNK DRIVING ACCIDENTS AND NOT
SUCKING UP THE BENEFITS LIKE THE
CHILD MOLESTER IN UTAH.
>> Laura: NONE OF THE MEDIA
OUTLETS DO MANY STORIES ABOUT
THOSE VICTIMIZED BY ILLEGAL
ALIENS IN THE UNITED STATES WHO
ARE CRIM ANALYSIS.
CRIMINALS.
I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING FOR
YOU.
JOHN KASICH WAS OUT THERE.
MR. NEVER TRUMP.
HE IS OUTRAGED THAT PEOPLE WOULD
NOT RESPOND IN A MORE
COMPASSIONATE WAY HERE.
>> IT COULD HAVE BEEN ALL OF US.
WE ARE IN THE CARAVAN.
WE ARE MARCHING NORTH TRYING TO
SAVE OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
CHILDREN.
WE HAVE TO START PUTTING
OURSELVES IN THE SHOES OF OTHER
PEOPLE.
LET US REACH OUT TO THOSE WHO
HAVE LESS AND STOPPING PUT UP
WALLS AROUND OURSELVES AND NOT
UNDERSTANDING THE PLIGHT AND THE
PROBLEMS OF OTHERS.
IT IS NOT RIDE AND THE LORD
DOESN'T WANT IT.
>> Laura: THE LORD DIDN'T WANT
HIM AS THE GOP NOMINEE.
SHOCKING THAT HE DIDN'T WIN THE
NOMINATION.
>> YES.
THAT'S JUST WHAT I WAS THINKING.
WHAT A SURPRISE THAT GUY DIDN'T
WIN!
AMERICANS ARE VERY
COMPASSIONATE.
OUR COMPASSION HAS WORN THIN.
THIS IS LIKE A CONMAN OR A GYPSY
APPEALING, OH THE POOR CHILDREN.
PEOPLE HAVE OUR OWN POOR PEOPLE.
WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR OWN
CITIZENS.
SORRY JOE SCARBOROUGH, WE ARE
BARELY HANGING ON TO MAJORITY
WHITE.
STOP SAYING IT'S WHITE AGAINST
THE BROWN THONGS.
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO OUR OWN
CITIZENS.
>> Laura: THESE PEOPLE OBSESSED
WITH COLORS.
THE MOST RACIALLY OBSESSED
PEOPLE IN THE UNITED STATES ARE
COMING FROM THE LEFT TODAY.
WE ARE FIGHTING FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE OF EVERY RELIGION.
ONE QUICK THING.
THE TRUTH SOMETIMES SLIPS OUT.
A MEMBER OF THE INVADING HORDE
ADMITTED WE HAVE SOME
UNDESIRABLES IN THE CROWD.
LET'S WATCH.
>> CRIMINALS EVERYWHERE.
OKAY?
THIS IS CRIMINAL HERE, IT IS.
>> Laura: [LAUGHING].
AT LEAST HE GAVE US THAT.
>> YES.
OF COURSE THERE ARE CRIM
ANALYSIS IN THIS GROUP.
EVEN IF WERE NO CRIM NAMES.
-- CRIMINALS, THEY ARE A MASS OF
VERY, VERY POOR PEOPLE.
THERE ARE 7 BILLION PEOPLE AND
THEY WOULD ALL LOVE TO COME TO
THE GREATEST SUPER POWER IN THE
WORLD AND THE GREATEST COUNTRY
IN THE WORLD WITH A MASSIVE
WELFARE STATE.
WE HAVE TO DRAW THE LINE SOME
PLACE.
MOST AMERICANS WERE SAYING ABOUT
20 YEARS AGO?
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO SAID PUT
AN END TO IT NOW.
HE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE FOLLOWING
THROUGH.
>> Laura: HE HAS TO.
HE SAID HE WILL CLOSE THE BORDER
IS NECESSARY AND 800 TROOPS.